[Music]
hey george campbell here co-host of the
ramsay show and i'm back with another
episode of the best of the ramsay show
every day we talk to those who are
millionaires or who want to know how
they can be one someday so in this
episode we cover toxic money myths
investing for the future and how to talk
to your kids about wealth nathan is in
richmond virginia hi nathan how can we
help
hi how are you doing better than i
deserve what's going on okay so here's
what i got going on um i'm 25 years old
i'm getting money from my father who
recently passed away
it's going to be over 200 thousand
dollars i'm not the best in money
management i've heard the saying it
takes money to make money should i
invest this money into a business should
i save this money what should i do if i
want to become a millionaire by the time
i'm in my 30s
[Music]
how long does your dad pass away nathan
um he passed away a couple months ago
i'm sorry y'all close
um we were pretty close he had dimension
alzheimer's so i didn't see him
um too often because he was in a
assisted living facility sure
and i lived across the country so he was
in arizona with my sisters and then i
lived over here in virginia
so you're getting 200 000 cash
it's not over that
it is just over that
yeah i'm not sure the exact number i
mean it's just it's not it's not a piece
of property or something else it's just
it's a
investments or cash that's going to come
to you liquid that you're going to do
whatever you want to do with it
yes like my brother's going to hand me a
check gotcha okay and uh what do you
make a year now
so a year i used to make around i'd say
35 000 a year okay all right
so here's what i would tell you um
you're calling very very wisely to start
to uh gather some wisdom about something
you don't know anything about you have
never driven a car before and someone
just gave you car keys
right cool
and you you go well i hear these things
go fast
right
and so
uh you know that and yet if you remember
the first time you got behind the wheel
of a car
uh it was both freeing because you could
now go places and control your own
destiny and it was uh terrifying
and if you don't have both of those
feelings with this process you're not
wise
right okay so uh i'll start with it
takes money to make money uh is not a
true statement that's a statement that
broke people say
as an excuse to not become broke people
can you make money using money sure
but actually the vast majority of people
who build wealth do not build it because
someone handed them two hundred thousand
dollars they built it because of their
habits and their character
okay so that's you
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to just what number one i tell you
to do is just slow way down
uh i would want you to move along the
spectrum from exciting to boring over
towards boring
your job is to manage
this money
your job as if it's someone else's money
and you're managing it for them your job
first is not to lose it
your job second
is to maximize it
but most people when they get handed the
keys to the car
step on the gas
and meaning they're they think their job
is to maximize it and they end up losing
it
so people yeah people that end up in
your situation get money lose it very
often because they make the mistake of
they think it has to be exciting it has
to be sexy it has to be wild has to be
crazy because if i don't maximize it i'm
doing something wrong it takes money to
make money we all know that and so i'm
gonna invest it over here and i'm gonna
do this and i'm gonna do that and i'm
gonna do this wrong
slow down
number one rule nathan don't put money
in something you don't understand
don't put money in something someone
else tells you is a good idea and they
sound like they're really smart people
around the money business and i've been
around at 40 years there are a lot of
enthusiastic ignoramuses
they mean well but they're dumber than a
rock
and they're excited about and they're
excited about their stupidity and they
will put you in stuff they'll put you in
stuff man and all your broke friends
also got an opinion already don't they
yeah and here's another piece too i
started a meat company but the thing
about it when i started this meat
company it's not my passion because i
was so money hungry to where i let money
kind of consume my mind
of oh i need to make my i need to make
money i need to be this by the time i'm
on this agenda i chase things that
weren't my passion and then i realized
as i got into it i'm like shoot i don't
want to do this anymore okay so let me
let's take a couple things number one we
can work on your career and that would
be a good use of a little of this money
if it got you into your passion i'll
hand off to ken in a minute and let him
work on that okay but then thing two
uh here's a rule if you were to invest
this money
and not touch it
in good growth stock mutual funds
and if it made 10
rate of return on average
in seven years it would double you would
have 400
and you would be what 29 years old right
no how do you say you're 25
25 yeah yeah okay so you'll be 32 years
old and fi in seven more years it would
double again and be eight hundred
thousand
and in seven more years it would double
again and it'd be a million six
and that is a boring
never touch it investment program you're
probably not gonna do exactly that but i
want a little of that in the formula
here my brother
okay where you go have a life and you
pretend you don't have this money and
you let it grow and double and grow and
double and grow and double and so here
my my last piece of instruction before
ken helps you on the career side is
uh i want you to go to daveramsey.org to
ramseysolutions.com and click on smart
vester sit down with the smart vester
pro and they will teach you
about mutual funds and then you can
decide
how much of this needs to go into your
career changes
and how much of it needs to go
into
mutual funds
and that just sit there and just double
so ken yeah real quick question here is
the meat company that you started is
that what's getting you the 35 000 a
year
yes all right and so you don't want to
do that what do you want to do i know
you got some ideas or one clear idea
what is it that you really want to do
so i really want to do fitness um
because even in the times when i was at
my lowest i always stuck to it
and it seems like it was like introduced
to me you know at a young age so is that
uh is that a fitness coach
trainer is that what we're talking about
so i want to compete in shows and i want
to launch um i want to be able to get a
following through the instagram and be
able to launch a business online and
help people um reach their fitness goals
yeah online because everything is online
now sure um
and also you know even in person but
doing it online it gives you that
freedom to do the travel all right so
let me make sure i heard this right you
want to be a fitness competitor and then
eventually develop some type of online
and in-person training business that's a
two-parter am i right
yes okay so here's the deal i'm gonna
caution you on this being a fitness
competitor is a whole different ball
game we only can make money when we win
so if that's the first goal you're going
to need a day job so you got to sit down
and go now what's the best strategy
here's what i would challenge you to
think through
um i would you're clear on what you want
to do that's stage one of my seven
stages stage twos get qualified so you
need to answer the question what is it
that i need to do to get qualified
to train people online now online
there's no technical qualification you
just gotta have good content that people
say all right i'm going to watch this
guy and i'm going to train the way he
trains but if you want to do it
one-on-one there's some qualification
that you need how much is that going to
cost you how long is that going to take
we're going to have to have a day job
still in all of this process
so if you've got the meat cup personal
trainer it could be a personal trainers
where i would go into so get qualified
to do that get in the proximity that's
it start doing that and then compete and
any money we make competing and the
online business it's going to grow over
time i would get in the field work for a
gym
um and have somebody else pay you to do
the training so that you can move from
meat company into this job and not
interrupt the income because dave we
don't want him to touch
this
i want you i 200
you to take twenty four thousand of the
two hundred thousand and set it aside
for a year's worth of two thousand
dollars a month yeah i want you to pay
yourself out of a little savings account
two thousand dollars each month for one
year during that year i want you to
develop a real
group of one-on-one personal training
clients that pay you well and you use
that money to eat with
so ken
this is an interesting and distressing
part of our world today
we did at ramsey a couple of years ago
the largest
by far
airtight
research
the largest study
of millionaires in north america in the
united states of america ever done
all the details where they come from
what do they think about did they
inherit their money what are their
careers what's their marital status
what's their race creed color whatever
everything we could figure out and
trying to find a and trying to figure
out okay what does it take
to become a millionaire
in america today a millionaire is a
million dollar net worth for those of
you don't know it's not a billionaire a
billion is a thousand million
it's a lot more
if you have
three thousand dollars you're closer to
being a millionaire than a millionaire
is to being a billionaire
as an example so it's not it's not
private jets and seven cars
okay that's not a millionaire a million
dollar net worth is not that much
it but it is more than most people have
there's about uh 17 million millionaires
in america
and that's what you own minus what you
owe
equals your net worth your assets minus
your liabilities is your net worth
so if you have no debt and you have a
million dollars in your 401k you're a
millionaire okay that's simple that kind
of a thing all right so we post on
instagram
yesterday
and this is what is societally
distressing
that from this study
not a feeling that we have we didn't ask
your broke brother-in-law his opinion
we ask real millionaires ten freaking
thousand of them
who they are where they come from
and one of the many
conclusions we drew from this was the
top 10
career fields that we found
according to frequency within the study
so who what career field did we find
most often
second most often and so on the most
often we found was engineer
the second was an accountant or cpa the
third was teacher
the fourth was management
the fifth was attorney
so not even making the top five is
medical doctor
by the way there were six
number six
but they were not even in the top five
and we post that on there
and instagram and facebook
proves once again
that humanity is full of morons
i mean if you read comments after
articles or comments after posts like
this you understand why some species eat
they're young
people are dumber than a rock out there
oh yeah a lot of mouthpieces some of you
listening are dumber than a rock
i mean i never heard this is ridiculous
so here's the thing okay we've done
detailed scientific research that proved
that the sun is hot
and we post it yeah on instagram the sun
is hot some of you morons will disagree
with that yeah
just because you think you have a right
to
and you should really stop before you
post something because it makes you look
stupid
okay was that unclear well probably i i
felt like you could have had a little
bit more enthusiasm for what you were
saying i felt like it felt like it lost
a little fervor no i think you're
absolutely right yeah this is data and
you know what's funny is like people
they want to argue like we're duping
people yeah like what we're just saying
yeah right dave ramsey teachers aren't
really making that kind of money not
where i live i'm a teacher teachers
can't be millionaires no way teachers
can be millionaires no teachers should
be on there where are the nurses where
are the nurses well you nurses get your
butt in gear and i guess you'll make the
dadgum list oh my gosh well what they're
missing what these brilliant mouth
breathers have forgotten in this post is
that it has nothing to do with the
salary has everything to do with the way
they live
now engineers certainly can make way
more money than a teacher but it is they
have lived on less than they make they
have saved they have invested they've
walked the clear path the baby steps
their baby steps millionaires and that's
what they're missing here they think oh
i know what a teacher salary is you guys
are just making this stuff up
as if you're into cleveland i'll tell
you what all five students share in
common all five professions are systems
people that's right they all work
systems yeah teachers work
a teaching plan they have a lesson plan
yeah they work a system and they they
they if they somebody gives them a
lesson plan they don't go make up their
own yep they they follow the lesson plan
and engineers they don't make up their
own thing the bridge would fall that's
correct they have to follow the system
they have to follow the processes
attorneys have to follow a process
called the law you know you don't get to
make it up you have to actually adhere
to a process all of these people adhere
to processes for a living and they take
that same part of their personality and
they apply it to their money and voila
they become a millionaire so what is the
data on teacher income well right now
the median income in the united states
is 60 thousand dollars so now before
some of you folks start firing shots at
me on that i said median you know what a
medium is anybody know if you've been in
a good teacher's class you would have
known it's your law of averages you just
run your averages so there's no average
is different than median yeah i know but
i'm just saying if you if you look at
the across the board of what the median
salary is for a teacher it's 60. now
that means in some districts in the
united states like for instance i got a
friend who's teaching high school in new
york
upstate new york he's making over six
figures so this is across the board you
look at the median and now we go okay
this is what we're looking at in the
united states but again it is about how
they live on less than they make it's
not this study wasn't pointing to how
much they make it was how much they keep
and by the way there is one other
correlation between all of these
millionaires they love their work yeah
hi
80 percentile range eighty percent they
lose so let me help you with this if you
invest from age 30 to age 65
in a decent growth stock mutual fund 15
of 60 000
you'll have 4.8 million dollars yeah
there it is now you can also
fire off a bunch of comments about that
but that was math you don't really get
to negotiate with math yeah that's how
math works it just is or it isn't that's
right you don't get to make up your own
version that's not enough and so if
that's so if one if you only are
one-fifth as good as we teach right
i mean five million bucks 4.8 million
right okay you would still have one
million dollars right and from age 30 to
age 65
but dave that's all too clear cut and
simple for the keyboard warriors
there's got to be more complexity they
got to tear it apart it's got to be a
game
and that's unfortunate that's the sad
part the sad part is is that we have a
portion of our culture now who rather
than fix their life
and address the person in the mirror's
deficits instead wants a narrative that
declares them a victim there it is
that can't possibly be true dave because
if that's true i could do it
if you're if your study was accurate
what do you know about my study you just
you just
if your mouth was shut you wouldn't be
making noise oh my god but dave they're
mouth breathers so the mouth can't be
shut
seriously people
you really should abstain from the
comments section reading them or
commenting on them oh my gosh there's a
reason
that you and i both get so visibly
frustrated
with people that have a victim narrative
and insist on spreading their victim
narrative
we know
from
having worked with thousands and even
millions of people
that most anyone that follows a proven
process can go get a great job can get
out of debt and build wealth can have a
good marriage we know that people that
are that choose to control their
behavior in spite of the negative
influences from the outside in spite of
bad things having happened to them and
we all have challenges but in spite of
the challenges we know that people can
create for themselves carve out for
themselves a good life if they bother
when someone posts a negative narrative
that says oh teachers can't do it then
someone believes that or you're in an
echo chamber with a bunch of people that
says teachers can't do it then god help
us teachers believe they can't do it
and we know that that's not true and
you've then limited someone's belief in
someone's future and you've brought harm
to them and we love people and we love
people that so much we want them to win
and anything that keeps them from
winning including you debbie downers out
there we're you're going to be at the
tip of our sharp tongue yeah yeah i
agree with that and let me just say this
as much as we will take shots at people
that that are constantly negative and
cynical
i i do even you could do it if you quit
doing that i feel sadness over that
because because you've bought in some
form or fashion a false narrative you
have had some bad stuff happen to you
maybe somebody did something maybe you
made a mistake and you did something
dumb that doesn't disqualify you from
being a victor i've never read a
biography in my life and i've read a lot
of them uh where the the story the
person in the story that we're reading
about always did everything right had no
hardship had no self-inflicted wounds
had no disadvantages so i absolutely
agree with you we get fired up on this
because we're in the business of hope
we're in the business of giving people
hope that they can be who they're
supposed to be they can do what they
want to do um and yeah it really makes
me angry when people just go nah that's
all a pipe dream and uh yeah it
irritates us and we live in a world
today where people really are influenced
shockingly by the comment in the comment
section by the negative yeah and yeah
that's why negative it fires us up the
negative the negative good here's my
deal if you really believe that
then why do you feel like you got to
share that with everybody else i mean
you you have the right to believe and
say and i will always fight for liberty
to say and be negative and your that's
what you want to be great but don't
bring it around the rest of us yeah old
country's saying if you ain't got
something nice to say don't you say
nothing at all
i mean life is too short pastor friend
of mine used to say if it's not helpful
hopeful or promotes healing you don't
need to say it that's good
yeah it's not helpful hopeful or
promotes healing yeah you don't need to
say it yeah
and um i couldn't i could take it to
that advice occasionally too i just
called a whole bunch of people stupid so
but i think that might have been healing
though i think it was it was it was a
little therapeutic for both yeah me and
you were healed by
it lauren's with us in richmond virginia
hi lauren welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call god bless you i love what you do
thank you love what you do how can we
help
um
we are a happy happily married couple 25
years um
just about to be empty nesters um and we
feel like we have missed the financial
boat uh so to speak we um
we started out uh ready to invest around
uh 2001 when the tech crash happened and
um so we
didn't invest in the stock market and
things like that because we're concerned
we just saved up enough money and we're
getting ready to invest when the 2008
real estate crash happened and
again we pulled back and did not invest
so we just stayed put and we just kept
saving and now all we hear is cash is
trash and
the american dollar is in trouble
and we don't we feel like we have missed
the boat and we're concerned
now
that maybe
we missed a way to help us retire how
much do you have in savings
two million dollars
okay i'm i'm
i'm absolutely amazed
and so all of this money is just money
you put in there because you've never
really made any money on your money
no we've hardly made any we have self
laddered cds and and done some bonds but
basically your rates of return have
sucked and you still put to got to two
million dollars
and and you're still afraid
to invest yes okay but you have two
million dollars so how did you miss the
boat
how big a boat were you wanting to get
on
i was going to say that's a great one
okay
but we're just we don't know now that
our kids stuff hasn't been paid for
college and things like that we just
never took any time to do anything or
plan for us
as much as just keep our head down and
work hard and now we picked our head up
but
did you miss you missed out on a bunch
of returns
that you could have had four or six
million instead of two million but you
still have two million dollars so i
don't think we can really cry river here
okay but when you say four or six
million that makes me really sad but i
there's no way to fix the power now all
you can do is think about the future
okay
so okay uh let me pair it back to you
what you said to me
every time you got up the courage to
invest
you found a negative story somewhere
that caused you to not do it
fear yes
yes
and now your new fear is the american
dollar is going to pot that's your
latest one yes that's your latest one
yes
and have you noticed that your other two
fears didn't come true
yes i don't like roller coasters maybe
that's the problem yeah but the roller
coaster even even with the roller
coaster
it you wouldn't have lost all your money
you would not have been broken homeless
uh that the 2008 real estate crash
actually had
almost i mean in the stock market crash
it came back and you know it went all
the way down to 6 300 and it's at 30 000
a day
and so
you know you missed out on all of that
yeah it's a ride but you know you're
going to either
uh not have you know if you had ridden
the roller coaster
you you know you might have had eight
million dollars
yeah
and so
even if the roller coaster screws up
it's got to really screw up to be
to en to end up with nothing you follow
yes and so i don't think that i i
personally am not of the belief that
america is coming to an end she's got
her problems
we have a whole truckload of idiots on
in both sides of the aisle in uh dc and
thank god it is not up to them
it's up to people like you and me out
here that get actually get things done
as to how this nation runs and whether
this nation works and whether we learn
to treat each other with some respect
out here
uh and so
you know this all this craziness on the
news cycle is just out of it's just
nutty everywhere so but all of that said
i don't think that well i'm 60 i'm older
than you and i have 100 of my retirement
in mutual funds uh and a whole bunch of
our wealth more than that
in
uh in real estate that i paid cash for
because i think in both cases they are
going to go up in value dramatically
more than cds will go up
now are they going to go straight up no
they go up and they go down and they go
up and they go down and can you stand
the ride
so let me give you an exercise or two
okay because here's the thing okay
there's two kinds of fear there's fear
that keeps you from touching a hot stove
or playing in traffic because those
things will get you hurt
that's good fear it protects you
the other fear is false evidence
appearing real
and that's the fear you've been
operating on
and i know that because for instance if
you will pull up
just go visit with one of our
smartvestor pros and ask them to show
you some examples don't buy anything
just go over there and start to learn
ask them to show you examples of during
these very volatile times what did
mutual fund a mutual fund b and mutual
fund c do
and follow what they did and say okay
had i invested in that through what i
feel like were very turbulent times i
don't like roller coasters
quote
here's the roller coaster ride i would
have signed up for
i think you perceive it to be the
world's tallest coaster
and you're going to go oh that's kind of
like the kitty park
when you actually look at the actual
history and the actual math
listen i don't like starting over i went
broke i don't want to start over so i'm
not investing in stuff that's high risk
either
i you know i don't i don't like extreme
volatility i don't like high risk i
don't personally invest in any of those
kinds of things
so i don't have money in bitcoin i don't
play the roulette wheel in vegas
i don't run up a bunch of debt trying to
make money i i do very low risk stuff
and so i think you need to learn about
the historical data
on some actual real mutual funds and you
will be amazed at how
much
less the risk was then your emotions are
perceiving it
and i think that'll help set you free
because here's the deal you're gonna be
fine you got two million dollars you're
gonna be fine congratulations you're
amazing that was an amazing task that
you've accomplished but if you keep in
mind this if it's invested at ten
percent rate of return instead of one
it's going to double every seven years
so when you're 64
you're gonna have go two to four to
eight
oh and when you're 71 it's 16.
if it's at one percent
it's not even going to go up a million
dollars between now and 74.
71.
so you're either going to have 2 million
or 16 million between now and early 70s
michelle is with us in cleveland ohio hi
michelle how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um
twofold i have um i got an esop
distribution from a company that i
worked for
and it's about 1.4 million
sitting in
a schwab account it's an ira
and i'm
with everything that's going on i'm
afraid about having all my eggs in one
basket
and my husband and i are both retired
i'm 61 he's 67
but we still have a mortgage and a home
equity line of credit
um
we don't have any credit cards we're
debt-free in the credit cards and up
until last week we had two paid off cars
but
an engine seized in one of our cars so
we had to go buy a car this week um
my question is whether to give them
what's going on in the world and
you know the great reset i was just
watching i have glenn beck's book and i
was just watching your program that
aired today
um
i'm just a little afraid
obviously of having all my eggs in one
basket
and given what's going on in the world
if we should just take i think there's
about 160 000 that we could take out in
cash and just pay everything off you
should do that anyway but not because of
the fear of what's going on in the world
it's a smart financial move
you sure you're
you've got a million dollars you should
not be carrying around a home mortgage
with a couple hundred grand you ought to
be paying it off
okay well that was that was my thought
process too but not because not because
of the great reset just because it's
smart to pay off your mortgage
okay okay then and same thing never
borrow money on car again you're a
millionaire come on girl
i know i was planning on paying it off
next year how about just never borrowing
on a car again
you're not a broke person you're a
millionaire now with the rest of the
money with the rest of money what i
would do is sit down with a smart vester
pro click ramsey solutions and click
smart buster pro and find somebody in
the investment business that can help
you do a rollover and get that
diversified across several types of
mutual funds and give you a little more
safety
yeah i'm with you i would not have it
all in one account but i'm not sure what
you've got with schwab there necessarily
you may not really be in one account but
i'd be in several different mutual funds
with that much money and i'd be
debt-free you could borrow money on cars
you're a millionaire
janelle is in cleveland hi janelle
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi george can you hear me okay
absolutely what's up
um
my husband and i are 65.
our kids are 32 and 30
and
i don't know when to tell them
how much money we have
now
now
well the only reason i'm hesitating is
because it's
1.5 million
yeah
so are they are they are they
misbehaving
oh no
no
why do you why do you think this
knowledge will bring harm
um probably the way i grew up
i didn't know
anything about my parents finances until
i was
gosh probably
my dad died 55 maybe
i mean my parents just never talked
about it i never asked them right
yeah lots of parents don't talk about
money or sex and then when their
children grow up they're surprised to
find out they had both
well they're both married and my
daughter is having a baby in about three
days so i think she knows about that
one down one to go i wasn't talking
about her sex i was talking about yours
but yeah i know
oh my gosh
yeah i i think you sit down now
you know when i had this conversation
with ours they were just coming out of
college
i didn't want them i wanted them to have
the maturity to be able to handle the
discussion the emotional and the
spiritual maturity
and uh we're a family of faith and so
the conversation started with this as
for me and my house we serve the lord
and so the information i'm getting ready
to explain to you is not
uh is not you hitting the lottery
because you are not inheriting the money
you're inheriting the responsibility to
manage the money for god
and that's how we started the discussion
and that's still how we have the
discussion to this day they've yet to
inherit any money but
but they know they know what our wealth
is in detail and they know exactly
what's going to happen to every penny of
it uh we have a big meeting once a year
with our leadership team at our office
and with our kids and we go over the
real every piece of real estate we go
over uh you know any of the wealth that
is there and exactly how the we'll
remind everybody how the wheels and the
trusts all work because it's kind of
complicated
and um you know we just have a review of
this and this is a transaction
so long ago they got past the emotions
of feeling like they hit the lottery
well i guess i'm wondering why why why
do i
what's the purpose in it because you can
teach them
to have the proper spiritual and
financial stance on this while you're
alive
otherwise you don't know what the
reaction is going to be and if you get a
negative reaction you may want to adjust
some of your inheritance
hmm
okay
because we i just yeah we don't leave
peop money to people in our family if
they're misbehaving because we don't
want to finance misbehavior with god's
money oh no
no i wouldn't do that i know but how
about their
how about their son-in-laws or our
son-in-law same thing
listen if it's going to affect the if
the information that this money is there
is going to affect them how much more do
you think the money is going to actually
affect them
when it comes out of left field
and there's no time to emotionally
process it oh by the way we're also
processing the death of a loved one at
the same time
so the so you think the son-in-law
should be included in absolutely
they are at my house
because they may they're they're they're
family
they're not necessarily going to
actually personally get the money but
their spouse is
and so you dadgum right and you get to
speak to all of them
about what this means to you and and how
we you think they ought to view this and
that we're not going to allow you to
feel like you can put co push the car up
into neutral because this is coming you
know we can have all kinds of good
discussions it's all kinds of teachable
moments
amy is with us in dallas hi amy how are
you
i'm doing great mr ramsey and uh rachel
i have to say i love that you're on
because i too like to spend a portion of
my entertainment budget at the crap
stables even though
it doesn't improve
this is not the way to start out the
call amy
is dying i mean you just you started out
in the hole okay and now you gotta dig
out amy could have said conspiracy
theories craps or love is blind and i
would have been like this is my
girlfriend
i am on baby step seven i am a i'm 33
years old um i think i have a pretty
good net worth of around two million
i don't i so i hope i'm hoping i'm
getting better on your graces in spite
of spider your problem with the craps
okay
yeah
um so i i'm an engineer my husband's an
engineer we're very process oriented
people
we're just kind of struggling like we we
just read the legacy journey
and like you know like what our next
like goal should be we really don't want
to be landlords no offense
i'm not offended but
um
so and now right now we're just
you know we have pretty substantial
raises this year so we're going to make
30 000 more than we made last year
and it's just it's just
like it feels like there's just more
money coming in and we're like you know
i guess we're just saving more
yeah well you're doing great you've done
such an amazing job congratulations when
you are the everyday millionaire of
uh our babysitter's millionaire of both
sure
yeah two engineers i mean everything
you're like the classic
except the fact that you're 33 yeah way
to go amazing
yeah so your biggest problem is
it's just um
you're overwhelmed with prosperity in a
sense
right yes and and obviously we're we're
christians and and we give and i i even
put in my budget random giving above the
you know 10 like until
it's just and now i just feel like it
was just
like our last goal was paying off our
house right and then there was like
making sure our kids college fund is set
and we don't have to touch it forever
and
it's like now what
okay yeah i mean it's i mean at this
point i mean you really we always say
the three things you can do with money
you can give it
you can save and invest it and you can
spend it and so you need to be doing all
three of those so i love that you upped
your giving
uh because that's a big part of this
right that you live like no one else so
later you live and give like no one else
right so
uh having that flow out is gonna be it's
gonna be amazing i mean like you're
gonna run into things and god's gonna
put things in your path
that you didn't even realize was there
and it's gonna come up and you're gonna
be able to write a check or you're gonna
be able to help someone in a significant
way which is just so fun and so you're
gonna get to experience that on a new
level
uh and then yeah i think continuing to
invest so if real estate's not something
that you're like oh you feel you know
great about or you guys want to do
um obviously just even opening up a
mutual fund talking to a smart investor
pro and continuing to to put money in
just investing
uh is something that you could look at
but if you guys i don't know if you have
an interest of like
i don't know you want to
i never know what you think about this
stuff but i don't know i don't know yeah
okay that's the spin category so i want
you to up your lifestyle for sure yes
and you all enjoy something that's our
problem okay let me
tell you let me tell you what's
happening because it happened it's
happened to me years ago
um and i watch it happen when i'm
working with people hit these uh the
baby steps millionaire's goals and they
get where you are okay
what happens is there's two things one
is you had this hard concrete goal
and it was the end of the race and you
broke through the tape
and you're like okay i need to i need a
goal because this feels like i'm just
kind of floating out here that's thing
one that happens this sense of
disconnect because you were so connected
to and driven towards a goal now there's
nothing and it's just floating
and that's very disconcerting the second
thing that happens is and this is more
pronounced than than that one that one
you do get over fairly quickly just by
getting another goal but the second
thing that happens is when you didn't
when you haven't been around this many
zeros
you emotionally it takes a little while
to get used to it i mean i'll give you
an example around here i mean the ramsey
organization is several hundred million
dollars a year in revenue and so we
spend more on copier paper
than i used to spend than i used to make
in a year
you know we spend more on coffee than
some people make in a year you know i
mean it's just nuts just because of the
scale right and it's hard to get used to
even today and i've been doing it for 30
years you know so but today i look down
at our profit loss statement and i see
the bill for coffee and i'm like jeez
you know and it's an emotional
experience i'm a kid from antioch
tennessee we spent that on coffee you
know and it's just kind of weird it's
it's an emotional thing so it takes a
little while for your emotions to catch
up with your math
for you to get used to
buying something
that cost
30 000 bucks
and you don't even feel it like most
people buying a candy bar
okay because that's the position you're
moving into you're going to be able to
go and buy an item
or a thingy of some kind a trip whatever
for your just to enjoy
just to consume
that is a large amount of money compared
to the way you grew up compared to what
you've always been up to this date
but it's a small amount of money
relative mathematically to where you are
and so you still have this like oh my
gosh you know
and so i was with a guy i'll give you an
extreme example of that okay i was with
a guy not long ago who made 15 million
dollars last year he's he's killing it
okay
and
actually would know his name if i said
it so i'm not going to say it but the uh
but he drove up to my house in a car
that cost 300 grand
and we were having this exact discussion
because the car is freaking killer
believable car you know and we're
standing there looking at this and he
goes man i grew up in dot dot dot and he
goes i can't even
i can't get my head around the fact that
i just bought this car and i just drove
it up here in your house he goes i feel
like kind of dirty like i did something
wrong well let's do the percentages 300
grand as a percentage of 15 million
okay it's like buying a thirty thousand
dollar car if you made a million and a
half a three thousand dollar car if you
made 150 000
it's the same ratios
right so did you do something wrong no i
didn't you know he's not out of line
it's a small but people say stuff like
no one needs a car like that well for
him it's like buying a biscuit
you know it doesn't show up it doesn't
move the needle and so that's where it
is with you your emotions are having
that same kind of a thing when you
invest a large sum give a large sum i
mean the first time i gave ten thousand
dollars to something my mind was blown
i was like whoa
you know
and and because it was the most i had
ever done and it was not an emotional
amount i was used to
and so that's what you're experiencing
so expect to feel disconnected until you
have a good goal and expect for it to be
emotionally disconcerting for a little
while as you lay out and say we're going
to spend x on enjoyment we're going to
spend y on investing and we're going to
spend
z on giving and you're going to increase
all of those and they're going to be
uncomfortable yes so amy i would say
like my husband and i once we we all we
always kind of have a goal we have a
goal within a 12 24 month period that we
can hit
uh whether it's a new car or we want to
do you know a certain trip or
i don't know put it in a pool like i
don't know what it is
a house was a big one for us so in 2019
is when we moved in but that was a goal
we had for years to do that so find the
thing you and your husband
i'm assuming i'm i'm going to assume
you're married i think you said that but
they shouldn't have to engineer that's
right that's right um that you guys are
excited about like have that goal that
you're yes putting money in a mutual
fund all that but that goal it's there's
still something energizing that you have
to be able to shoot for so find
something
that you and your husband agree like
that's fine whether maybe it's building
your dream home like i don't care what
it is but there's something out there
that you look at and you guys are
continuing to work and be intentional
and then on the lifestyle side i would i
would force yourself force yourself to
spend
a certain amount of money every month
just to get used to it because you can
and you should be able to enjoy it too
that would be very nice and on the
generosity above the tide the generosity
above the tithes should go up all of
these are going to be a little
uncomfortable because it's your first
time to play with numbers this size it's
emotionally like looking at the coffee
line and going what
hey if you like this episode click here
for the next one all about toxic family
situations around money